so hello everybody who was here
yesterday first question
so most people hopefully we're here
yesterday because tonight is going to be
the kind of the continuation of what we
talked about yesterday for those who
weren't there I'm going to give you like
a 30-second rundown we basically talked
about the Garden of Eden in the work of
Saint Ephrem and Saint Gregory of Nyssa
especially and how the garna being is
this ontological hierarchy it's a it's a
hierarchy of being a hierarchy of virtue
a hierarchy of being and it flows out
into the world it's it's basically the
the the virtues of the garden go out
into the world and the farther you are
from the tree the further you are from
the glory of God and you know that's the
fall of Adam and Eve that move out and
so that's the shape of everything the
shape of a church the shape of Mount
Sinai
when Moses goes up the shape of the
Tabernacle in the Old Testament of the
temple all these have the same kind of
shape
but today I want to talk a little bit
about what happens on the edge and the
reason why I want to talk about that is
because usually when I usually when I
talk about this subject if I talk about
it with people that aren't familiar with
Christianity that aren't in the church
usually I start at the edge because it's
in our world today it's a lot easier to
understand the edge but with you guys I
decided to start with the middle and
then we're going to move out and I'm
going to talk a little bit about what it
looks like when you come to the edge of
things now in order to understand it we
need to I'm going to revisit the story
just a little bit revisit the basic
story and I'm gonna show you how it
relates to other other structures as
well now if you think again about the
Garden of Eden and you think about the
fall the way to understand it is if you
understand it spatially
you have to understand that the mountain
going all the way you could say down
down down until they reach the flood so
Adam and Eve and their descendants
there's this tumble and they they fall
Cain and Abel Cain kills Abel there's
another foe and then Cain goes out build
cities builds weapons and the world
becomes more and more corrupted until
God sends the flood what happens before
the flood there's that strange verse in
the Bible right a strange verse that
says that the sons of God had children
with the daughters of men and it
produced Giants produced monsters so on
the edge of the world we find the
monsters now if you think about going
backwards if you think about when the
Israelites leave Egypt and they go back
towards the Holy Land a way to
understand it is you can look at this
story backwards so Adam and Eve follow
they tumble they move away from the holy
place and now they're actually going
back to the holy place so what are the
things that they encounter they
encounter a flood right they cross the
waters and then when they come to the
Holy Land what do they encounter Giants
you gotta beat the Giants that's you
beat the Giants then you then you they
they have several crossings in the story
where they keep crossing these bodies of
water to show you this moving back you
know crossing these transitions and
moving back towards the towards the Holy
Land
now the ancients in other cultures in
Greek culture Roman culture and other
cultures they understood the world
pretty much exactly like that so you
have you're usually they would have
their own middle their own center in
Greece they had the bellybutton of the
world right the omphalos they had this
idea that they they
had the bellybutton of the world and the
more you moved away from the bellybutton
the more you had encountered things that
you that aren't like you you start to
encounter barbarians and remember that
the word barbarian most certainly
probably comes from the notion of
barking like a dog bar barbar when you
listen to someone you don't understand
you just hear noise right
I have barbarians and then on the edge
of the world what do you have monsters
yes thank you at the edge of the world
you have monsters if you look at ancient
maps you know even medieval Maps that's
how they would show it they would show
Jerusalem in the center and then they
would show the world and on the edge of
the world there would be monsters and
monsters represented all kinds of
different ways people with their faces
in their stomach people with one foot
you know people who who had dog heads
and cannibals all these all these
monsters that live on the edge of the
world now it's very difficult for people
to think like that today but like I said
this is just the shape of reality this
is how we encounter things this is how
everything unfolds and so it's difficult
for us to think of it in that kind of
large way but you can think about it in
terms of anything so imagine you have I
can take I take any object a chair right
you have you have a chair and there's
something about it that makes it a chair
there's a chair ness of the chair right
something that makes it that you know
that it's a chair then you see different
variations of chairs right and they will
though let's say they'll congregate to
the notion of chair and slowly as you
move away you could start to have have
some weird chairs right you can have a
chair maybe with three legs does that
still a chair maybe no could be what
about a chair that doesn't have a back
or maybe you have another category
like like a couch and somewhere in
between there's this weird thing that
you see in someone's living room and
someone asked you what it was you would
say it's a chair couch I don't know it's
a it's a mixture it's a it's a mixture
between two things you're not quite sure
you know how it fits in terms of its
category and so that's what monsters are
monsters are just things that don't fit
in the category right they're usually
either too much of something that's big
too small or they they're a mixture with
animals or else they they have something
about them which is off right one leg
too many arms
you just keep going can imagine I've got
they have many eyes they have no eyes
they have whatever like anything you can
you can you can continue to there's an
indefinite amount of possible monsters
because there's an indefinite amount of
exceptions between the chair and the
couch would give you a little bit more
on this size little bit more on that
side and if you look at traditional
monsters if you look at a dragon for
example in Indian in the icon on st.
George if you look carefully you will
see that a dragon is really just a
mixture of different animals usually the
dragon and the icon of st. George will
have the the head of the lizard it'll
have hairy legs often and it'll have
wings and these are this is an animal
that cannot exist it cannot exist
because it is it is undefined but it it
defies categories okay and so you can
understand it that's let's say how the
world works and so once you understand
that then there's a lot of things about
the way that traditional imagery or the
way that the traditional world lays
itself out we talked yes we talked
yesterday about the notion of the
narthex and the fact that they would put
the Greek sages in the narthex and you
could say that those Greece ages or
something like monsters my
aren't always negative by the way
monster just means not sure not sure
what it is not sure how it fits that's
not that not properly integrated and so
you have these sinkers play-doh we have
Aristotle and the church uses a lot of
the language of Plato and Aristotle you
have some fathers that say like send
Justin Martyr who says that they're
Christians before Christ you have other
fathers who say what does Jerusalem have
to do with Athens are they in are they
out well the kind of like in between so
what do we do put him on the edge put
him in the narthex and either inside nor
outside we can't totally put them
outside because you put them outside
we'll have a serious problem because a
lot of the words we use actually we take
them from these people can't totally put
them inside because obviously they
didn't they didn't they weren't part of
the story of the Incarnation they they
didn't they did they didn't receive the
Holy Spirit the way that we received the
Holy Spirit as we enter into the church
and so we have this buffer right this
this buffer in between now that buffer
repeats itself at all the layers - okay
and so and you come into the temple and
if you come into the tabernacle and you
want to go into the Holy of Holies what
do you see you see a terror now in
Indiana Jones when they show the cherubs
on the ark they show these nice angels
you know with wings that kind of bowed
and they're very pretty but if you read
the description of a cherub in the Bible
that's a little different right it's a
mix of an ox lion and eagle a man and
different descriptions in different
parts of the different places and the
text talks about God riding the chair of
across the sky like a mount you can
imagine this creature with like the legs
of an ox and that and the you know the
wings of a with wings and the head of a
bowl or the head of an eagle you have
this this wild image of this hybrid
creature that God is writing
he and honestly like the cherubs on in
the temple probably looked a lot more
like a sphinx or like the babylonian
images you see of the bulls with the
wings probably looked a lot more like
that
then the pretty kind of image that we
that we come to see especially in 19th
century or the little babies those
babies in the painting is having cherubs
very little to do with chair there is an
image of a cherub in one of the
monasteries in meteora I think somewhere
in one of the monasteries where they
really do show this warrior standing
with four wings and four heads you know
this is this really intense figure of a
defender right the cherub is a defending
the holy place so you encounter these
monsters going out you could also
encounter them in every transition and
those places where it's not sure there's
this little transition space you know
then if you if you once you realize that
a lot of stories are gonna start to make
sense to you a lot of stories that's not
even in the Bible like why is it that a
leprechaun guards a pot of gold at the
end of a rainbow
why does a garden why does why do
dragons guard treasures why do monsters
guard treasures because that's also part
of it they moving in or moving out
you'll find this buffer of in-between
okay and so that's why in the West
especially that's why what do we have on
the outside of churches in the Middle
Ages
we have gargoyles I like that one
because it looks like the Joker
do you think it looks like the Joker
to understand the gargoyles you really
do have to understand the function of
this intermediary space because the
Garbo as most of the gargoyles actually
had a architectural function right there
waterspouts
and so the what if you leave water on it
accumulate next to building what's going
to happen right it's going to destroy
the building right if you leave the
blood come right up to the gate it's
gonna start to eat at the gate so what
do you do you put a monster at the gate
and then the monster chases the water
away keeps the water at bay okay so a
way a way to understand it a way to
understand it is to understand it you
could understand it as a once you reach
a certain level you have a bunch of
series of monsters you could say like
different layers of monsters
so the first Monster is in the
traditional way of understanding the
first monster is the the person you
don't know right that you encounter some
encounter some culture you've never met
like you see someone a culture of
something that you've never seen you
can't recognize them you can't recognize
them as part of your world but behind
them there's another thing that you know
even less and behind that there's a
thing you know even less and that keeps
being represented as stranger and
stranger stranger and stranger and
bigger and bigger monsters until you
reach the Leviathan you know that's at
the bottom of the ocean that is there
too that could devour the world you know
the snake that's the snake around the
world as you see in the in the ancient
northern imagery or whatever this is
this final monster right that's at the
edge and so in in in the Middle Ages for
example they would have these gargoyles
on the edge of buildings but they would
also have these these exceptions these
strangeness they would also have it in
manuscripts and so the way that medieval
manuscripts were set up is that in the
sir you would have text and that and
then on the outside of the text you
would have ornamentation and then you
would have what we call marginalia and
marginalia is exactly that it's a bunch
of strange monsters so here is some
example of medieval marginalia and so in
the in the marginalia there are hybrids
you saw them strange creatures mix of
animal and man in versions where animals
often an animal will be writing some I
will be writing a man or you have men
fighting animals or you'll have you know
this this figure the standing donkey
who's standing like a man but he's a
donkey right so all of these things
happen on on the edge so on the edge of
manuscripts on the edge of the the
church you would have this this
marginalia and in the marginalia
i'm not going to show you some of the
images because i I reminded myself that
we were still in the temple but there
there's in in medieval marginalia
there's some pretty raucous imagery
there's a lot of there's as there's some
hints of obscenity there's potty humor
all that stuff like it's all there in
the marginalia okay and so there's also
humor right that's also part of the
margins is funny because none of you
laughed when you saw that but you have
to admit that in a world imagine in a
medieval world of monks and you open
this book and there we saw today it was
kind of funny to see that you see this
image of the Annunciation and then under
the knee under the image of the
Annunciation you have like some weird
hybrid creature that's fighting another
weird hybrid creature and so it's it has
that little okay yeah or it's kind of
surprising you know and I think I mean
seems to me that it was supposed to
somehow
bring about a little bit of it a little
bit of laughter and so that's why I want
to talk a little bit more about laughter
because if I tell you a little if I tell
you about these monsters on the edge of
the world and I showed this to you it's
pretty easy to understand it we can it's
kind of intuitively make sense
we understand it because we can have
that experience I always tell people you
can have that experience it's it's
harder today to have that experience in
terms of of seeing something but you can
have it in terms of hearing because if I
as let's say French English speaker if I
hear Spanish kind of familiar right it's
not it's not the same it's kind of
familiar from what I know you kind of
make out some words not everything if I
hear Russian I don't understand the
words but I can kind of follow the
rhythm let's say or the intentions I get
this descent there's some can find some
similarity but if I hear like Vietnamese
I don't know it's just noise I just hear
noise that I cannot make out even the
intentions in the so it is it presents
itself to me as chaos but of course in
their experience it's not chaos we're
talking about we're talking about this
idea of this experience that we have
that we have with the world they
probably have the same experience with
me they hear me and they just hear chaos
but that is a real experience of how we
encounter these layers let say of
knowledge and moving out towards this
kind of chaotic fringe on the edge and
so laughter is part of that now so
there's a tradition st. John Chrysostom
he has a few homilies where he goes
right after laughter and she tells us
that Christ never laughed and that that
laughter we have to be careful of
laughter because it's dangerous you know
where'd where it leads us and I remember
the first time I read that bit shocked
he does go on to say that laugh does not
in itself like he's careful to say that
his laps are not evil in itself it's
it's dangerous when it takes over right
so when you laugh uncontrollably and so
that is how we need to at least as we
look at the world moving out towards its
edge that's how we have to understand
laughter laughter is a involuntary
reaction in general it can laugh if you
want but in general laugh is an
involuntary reaction to something
something that presents itself to you
and usually what it is it's something
which is what do we wither if you think
of the basic things that we laugh at
what is what does it think of not not
anything sophisticated right think of
the most basic things that people laugh
at where do we laugh at what's the basic
one falling right that's the first
falling is the first thing that makes
you laugh what's the second accidents in
general including bodily accidents those
are the those are the primary source of
basic laughter hauling and bodily
accidents things that don't fit things
that are off right things that don't
upside-down and you could say right and
so it is this it is this encounter with
the edge it's exactly that right on the
edge are all these things that don't fit
all these things that are a little bit
off and this joining yourself with them
you know will and will bring about that
that laughter right and so I think that
that's probably why there is in st. John
Chrysostom for example this desire to
tell us to be careful of laughter
because if you think of the wheel that I
told you about yesterday think of it as
the
when I talked about it as being the
human person as being the soul as being
the image of the human soul you start
with the noose then you have the soul in
terms of the thoughts the will all of
that and then you move out towards
things that become involuntary you would
say or that go beyond your will your
passions they pull you out of yourself
they pull you away from yourself and
laughter is you could say the ultimate
example of that because you something
happens and makes you laugh and you
don't totally control it now I don't
think there's anything I don't think
laughter is wrong but I think it's
interesting it's very important to think
about that right because if you think
about our world
so Abba ABBA I forget out renounce the
name but how about poimen says that
distraction is the root of all evil
yesterday we talked about attention we
talked about remembering God this notion
of keeping attention in the heart
remembering God and and and laughter is
exactly that little moment of forgetting
that little moment where you humble into
the outside you could say but what's and
and if you look at the the monstrous
aspect or the strangeness it presents
itself for 21st but it always ends on
the danger of tipping into something
else right I always tell people just
think of clowns here's a question our
clowns funny or our clown scary not sure
which one not sure people can really
tell me because they seem to be both at
the same time for some reason it seems
to kind of move in to move into one move
in moving into the other and in our
cultural representations as well they
seem to kind of move in one into the
other so obviously when you come to the
ultimate edge you get this image of the
devil to this image especially in the
West the image of the devil is exactly
image of the strange mixture of a man
with horns and a tail and hooves and all
this all this chaotic representation of
a figure I'm not going to leave it on
there too long now
[Music]
if you look at this edge you could say
you come to this this this moment of a
of distraction of laughter all of that
we hopefully you can see that in general
this is pretty much where we are right
now our our society is obsessed with
distraction we are basically our whole
world is focused on distraction non
entertainment our all our cultural forms
have become entertainment and that's
really hard for people to understand
that there was a time when cultural
forms were not entertainment when our
when folk dancing was there to bring
communities together when music was
there for you to participate in in order
you know like we do in the liturgy but
the out even out in the world it was a
way for people to come together and
participate in a cup in a common
language in a common expression all of
this was what cultural manifestations
were doing festivals you know different
celebrations all of that
that's what cultural manifestations were
we have pretty much not completely
eliminated those but we're getting very
close to eliminating those and all that
is left of what we call culture is is
entertainment all right movies just the
type of music the idea of sitting
somewhere and listening to music alone
that is something that the ancients
could never even have imagined think why
would you listen to music alone music is
there to bring us together so I want to
be careful I'm not saying and it's
important I am NOT saying that there's
anything wrong with any of these
cultural expressions I watch movies I
listen to music but I do think that it's
important to understand as a whole this
moment in culture and to be able to
speak to it because it is this we have
come to the
edge like we have come to the edge where
we are obsessed with distraction when
you see something like attention deficit
disorder become a disease and you know
even 40 years ago thirty years ago no
one had ever heard of that didn't even
exist
and all of a sudden everybody has
attention deficit disorder that is
because we are lacking in attention we
we haven't we have a social incapacity
for attention we have a social purpose
proficiency towards distraction and
everything around us is there to to
bring us along that road towards
distraction so the question is how do we
deal with that how do we deal with the
with the upside-down world how do we
deal with this world at the edge and I
think there are many ways to deal with
it but I think that it is also possible
to see it through the lens of laughter a
little bit I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
try to give you some examples to maybe
help you see how we can get to it
because it's interesting st. John
Chrysostom if you read his homily
it's Hamid has a homily in Matthew and
homily in Hebrews where he really goes
after laughter and he he basically says
right nowhere in the Bible do people
laugh like it's the only places where
people laugh in the Bible is when Sarah
laughs that she was told she would have
a child and so laughter is incredulity
and Christ says you know whoa - those
that laugh were you will weep and so he
really lays it on but I think that there
is actually there is in there on the
Bible moments where there is laughter
and I want to show you some of those
moments so that you can see how it fits
in the in the in the system you could
say in this image in order to understand
this story you have to understand you
could say the two sides of I'm already
gonna reveal what I'm going towards but
I still have to say it or else you want
to understand you have to understand the
two sides of nakedness okay
there are you could say there's two
removing of the garments talked about
this idea of removing the garments
there's removing the garments moving
towards the let's say moving towards the
the center towards the tree towards the
garden but there's another removing of
the garments right which is this peeking
into the scandal like seeing the scandal
that's one of the things that makes
people laugh I show you the scandal then
that's part of the part of the left
it can also be part of other part of the
anger too but you know when Christ says
everything will be revealed he was also
including this notion that how the
scandals will be revealed as well and so
this notion of being shown to be naked
like in the story of the king the who
the the King how do you call that story
in English the emperor with no clothes
there's a there's an image of someone
who is disrobed in a manner which
exposes his his stupidity which exposes
his his the fact that he is not worthy
of being king so he's being disrobe
that's the fact by the way that is the
function of the gesture right that's
always been the function at function of
the court jester so the court clown was
there to disrobe the King a little bit
to keep him humble right to expose some
truths about him some unfortunate truths
about the king that would expose him a
little bit so that she'd never thought
that he was everything right and that
was the role of the of the clown at the
edge and in general that's maybe the
positive role of all clowns that's kind
of what the positive roles that they can
play is to be able to show that the
emperor has no clothes to reveal the
scandal okay so this is the story of
Christ in the garden and this is the
story this image is follows the same
image as what I told you yesterday the
mountain the Garden of Eden memory
attention it's all there so what happens
Christ comes to the Mount of Olives and
he tells his disciples to stay down
there and what does he tell them to do
tell them to stay awake stay awake stay
attentive remember and Christ goes up on
the mountain Christ comes back down what
is he fine finds them asleep they'd
forgotten they've lost the tension and
they end and sleepy if you want to get a
beautiful image what is sleep akin to in
our tradition death so forgetting losing
attention and dying so there they are
they're fallen right Adam and Eve right
they're falling at the that's the bottom
of the mountain
Christ does it three times he tells them
be attentive stay awake they can't fall
asleep and then comes the flood right
there comes the flood and so the
betrayer comes the foreigners come you
know the army comes come to get Christ
and they pulled everybody and everybody
scatters but think about the wheel again
think about the wheel here's Christ that
percent goes up to the top of the
mountain right and he encounters an
angel he he he links up with the higher
levels he brings it all together you
know and then going back down everything
scatters and everybody runs in their own
direction and in that moment what
happened in the Gospel of st. mark
probably the text nobody likes to cite
it doesn't say who some people think
it's a mark because it might be st. mark
but Roman soldier grabs the tunic st.
mark runs away naked there's a joke in
that story it's a joke I'm sorry I hate
to tell you that's a joke right
that is a joke it's a little joke in the
most intense one of the most intense
moments in the entire New Testament they
this little strange moment where someone
grabs the disciples clothing and he runs
out naked in the scandal of his
abandoning his Lord okay so you can see
this structure this pattern okay now in
our in the gospel there's also enough in
the Old Testament we see some examples
of that this example of what happens
when we come to the edge and things turn
upside down right and how does laughter
participate in that the best version is
in the story of Elijah in the story of
Elijah we have a cup side down world
people of God King married a foreign
Queen and this foreign Queen brings with
her foreign gods and all of a sudden the
prophets of God they're the ones being
marginalized they're the ones being
persecuted they're the ones who have to
hide in a cave well upside-down world
and Elisha death is myth you know what
hizmet means means the stranger here's
this upside-down world where all of a
sudden the prophet of God goes to Israel
but he is appears as the stranger
topsy-turvy everything is upside-down
how does he like to deal with that how
does he manage that he uses laughter
that's how he does it he mocks the
prophets about
makes fun of them because he sees how
upside-down everything is and so all of
a sudden he lied she becomes the clown
it's weird to think of him that way but
just imagine the scene imagine that
scene when he's standing there with the
prophets of bow you know and he's
pouring water over his thing and he's
like he's pouring water and then in that
the prophets of Baal are they're trying
to call up the call to fire and they're
trying to get it to burn it's not going
and you lied you just call the fire down
and I mean that's funny
it's a funny moment in the Bible right
yeah it's a it's a it's a funny but it's
a funny moment in the it's a funny
moment in the Bible and that I think is
the possibility I think and I'm saying
this with a little bit of trembling as I
tell you but I think that that possibly
is the role of laughter in our time
right now in our in our situation and
you see the same thing with some of the
martyrs you see the same thing with some
of the martyrs where you you know this
is the story of st. Lawrence does the
people know the story of st. Lawrence
st. Lawrence was tortured tortured and
he was put on the grill when they came
to see that he was dead he said you
should turn me over that's right
that's humor
and so coming up to the edge I think
this is this is the place I this is
something I've been thinking about for
quite a long time this is the place
where possibly that laughter can be
useful or can help us in this situation
we are today and if you don't see that
we're living in an upside-down world
right now I'm not going to explain it to
you
let someone else explain it to you but
it seems pretty sure that we are in that
moment at this time so I'm going to tell
you one last story that I like a lot
it's a some of you who watch my videos
have heard the story it's the story of
silence the story of silence is not from
Bible it is an Arthurian romance it's a
it's a it's a little-known or three in
romance which is kind of reven
rediscovered and i think it can help us
understand this role so in the story of
silence this young woman is born in a
world in the medieval world where the
King has declared that women are not
allowed to inherit and so silence
silence his father who wants his child
to inherit tell silence I'm going to
raise you as a boy so I'm gonna raise
you as a boy and you have to be quiet
about it don't tell anybody
so silence is raised as a boy and in the
story it's really really fascinating
because these two allegorical characters
appear there's nature and nurture
the medieval is knew what they're
talking about and there's a debate
between nature and nurture whether or
not silence is acting the way that
silence is in nature telling silence
this is a fraud this is a scam you're
joking with yourself this isn't this is
impossible and nurture is telling
silence no you're doing fine you're
doing okay yeah you're look at look at
the way you're dressed look at the way
you're acting you're fine okay so
silence grows up and science actually
becomes a night cuz I'm pretty valley at
night actually
because silence is such a valley at
night he I'll say he because in the
story they actually used the male
pronoun for sentence while he's up
acting as a man silence is called to the
king's court and when silence arrived in
the king's court the wife of the king
see silence and becomes completely
enamored with silence and falls in love
and love falls in lust with silence
tries to seduce silence but silence of
course refuses the advances of the queen
and so the queen gets very angry so what
did she do you know the story we know
the story of Joseph right same story so
she tells her husband that silence tried
to rape her and so her husband is so
angry but the problem is that silence is
such a great night and it's so beloved
by the court and the King doesn't know
what to do not sure how to deal with
this situation so he the the Queen says
well there's this there's a legend that
says that Merlin has become wild he's to
come up a wild man and he lives out in
the forest very far away and no one can
catch him
no man can catch him no man is able to
catch him only a woman could catch him
so send silence out to get Merlin and
that way you get rid of silence he won't
be able to accomplish the task so you
will be too ashamed to come back problem
set it so king sends silence out to find
Merlin in the forest Merlin has become a
total wild man he is hairy all over his
body
he lived in the forest and he eats roots
and grass and he lives with the animals
silence has to try to to catch him and
she set traps for him she first of all
she puts forget the order of it yes the
first thing she does is she puts a jar
of honey and then she no she put some
meat down sorry she put some meat out
and so Merlin eats the meat because he
gives in to his human come by he wasn't
eating meat you just
grasan to that she eats the meat and
then she puts a jar of honey because he
knew she knows who he'll be thirsty
after he's eaten the meat so he tugs
this jar of honey but obviously and then
after that she puts a jar of milk so she
put takes the jar of milk but that
doesn't help he drinking honey drinking
milk and then she puts a jug of wine
like chugs the wine and then she's got
Merlin obvious is confused and he's like
how is it that a man could ever catch me
this is it and then he looks at silence
and he starts just make her he kind of
starts to snicker and so sine is like
I'm gonna bring you back I need to bring
you back to the to the Kings Court he
starts to drag Merlin back to the Kings
Court and on the way they see a they see
a man whose child has died and there's a
priest who is sensing the tomb and the
man is there and so Merlin is calling by
the stripes to laugh and he's just
laughing and laughing and silence like
this is completely unacceptable how can
you laugh as you see this this horrible
situation and then Merlin continues
comes to a place where there's
beggars who are begging for something to
eat and just begging for something to
eat and then Merlin's just starts
laughing and laughing and laughing he's
just laughing and so that continues on
and they bring they bring Merlin all the
way back there's a third one and now for
some reason I can't remember it so they
bring rolling back to the castle and
then when Merlin comes in he sees the
king and he starts laughing he's just
can't prevent himself and the queen is
offended and she sends this nun that is
her guardian - stunned it that his with
her and the nun comes to Merlin to
chastise him and he looks at the nun and
then he loses it he's just on the ground
and he can't stop and - and then the nut
and the the wife is also extremely angry
but then he laughs at the white so he's
laughing at the king he's laughing at
silence he's laughing at the wife and
he's laughing at this nun and everybody
is saying what is going on so the King
tells Merlin you
have to tell us what is going on why is
it that you laugh so much this is
completely unacceptable first of all why
did you laugh at the the beggars who
were begging for food and really says I
laugh because they thought they had to
beg for food they thought that that
there was nothing but what they didn't
know they thought that everything was
scarce what they didn't know is that
right under their feet there's a
treasure that's buried there they don't
even know that the treasure was buried
there so the king sends his guards and
they dig out find the treasure
alright so Merlin was right then he says
why did you laugh at that poor man who
lost his son and says well if the man
only knew that that wasn't his son and
it was in fact the son of the priest
maybe he would have been laughing as
well so then they go and they check and
they find out and they discover that in
fact that is the exact situation but
then the question is why did you laugh
at us why did you laugh at all of us and
so Merlin says well I laughed it and he
laughed at himself
- Merlin was laughing at himself I said
I laughed at you King and I laughed at
myself because both of us had been
tricked and I laughed it at at silence
and I laughed at your wife and the nun
because there are some also that are
tricking the King said you have to be
clear you have to tell me and run said
you sure you want me to tell you Merlin
tells it he says first of all he says
silence is a woman and so because
silence is a woman the story about how
she treated your wife is not possible so
the king is shocked and he can't believe
it and he says know what else the nun is
a man
and so everything falls into place and
then silence takes on her role takes on
her position as a woman because the King
declares that because of all this chaos
because of all this then he will let
women inherit and so he lets silence
inherit and it gets even better because
he marries her she becomes the queen and
of course I won't tell you the the the I
won't tell you what the the punishment
is for the others but it's it's made a
very medieval and so that story to me
there are so many parallels to what is
happening today there's so many
parallels about this topsy-turvy world
and the possibility maybe of laughter to
point out the madness that we're
surrounded by point out the incongruity
is the upside down this of the world
right and so I want to just show you one
thing I honestly I try in my life to
avoid politics but I want to show you a
tweet from someone someone I don't even
follow all right and I want to show you
the tweet and I want to just read it and
you'll see the possibilities of what
we're doing
so this is Matt Matt wall she's a
Catholic blogger so Matt wash says
gender is a social contract but I am a
woman hear me war but anybody can be a
woman but no uterus no opinion but trans
women are women but I demand women's
rights but men are women but men are
scum a drag queens are beautiful but
appropriation is evil so in the
upside-down world in the fragmented
world what happened is that things that
don't make sense don't make sense
they don't fit together that's the whole
idea of something which is a monster is
something that's on the edge something
that is on the fragmented fringe they
don't fit together all the gargoyles are
different they don't form a community of
gargoyles there is no community of
gargoyles okay and so as we look at the
world and it's it's upside down this and
it's madness it is possible to show how
those things don't fit together and
light hardness and let's say a joyful
laughter can help us because the other
option is to become cynical the other
option is to become to to hide in a cave
like the prophets in the story of Elijah
the other option is for us to pretend
like we're not living in this mad world
and so this is just a hint at least you
can hopefully at least from my talk you
can understand and see the relationship
between this hierarchy and the world of
distraction the world of entertainment
and also the world of could call it the
tyranny of exceptions right the tyranny
of the fragments and that's
right that's an image of the passions
for our own self right that's exactly
what happened we have all these things
on our fringe and when you give in to
our passion we give we give in to the
tyranny of our of our fringe you could
say it's a way to put it and so that is
what I had to to present for you tonight
and so hopefully people have questions
or if you're angry that's okay too
and you can express that if you want yes
Father
yeah
go back to the days because monsters
into syringe we kept laughing
yeah that's true that's also weighted
that's another way
[Music]
or later and multiple answers in depth
so that what you see is the way
the church and the world were living
[Music]
what do we do mission evangelism
[Music]
I think I think that the solution is a
proper engagement with hierarchy that's
what I think I think that and I've
expressed this before and other talks I
think that we need to keep the altar
pure we need to keep the holy things
holy we need to to to elevate that which
needs to be elevated right and then we
also need to leave room in the narthex
to understand that in a world of madness
and exceptions if you you can't shut it
out completely you have to engage in
that world so if you if you're able to
do both at the same time and I know it's
very difficult I think that I think that
that seems to be the solution one of the
problems we've seen and I think in the
Orthodox Church in America is we've seen
we've seen the two extremes you could
say where some people want to shut it
down right it's like this is us we're
the people of god we're the pure you
know we are the close ourselves off in
order to remain pure and to have have
that and I can understand that and then
there's also another tendency which is
let's open it all up let's have no more
veils take them all out because we want
everybody everybody can come in and
everybody can see everything and there's
no we've eliminated the mystery out of
this desire to kind of let say preach to
the world you could say and I think that
the solution is to is to have that to
have them is to have the middle ground I
think that that's the solution I mean I
don't know in practice what that looks
like but I think that like for example
father some of the things that you're
doing if you're you know you're doing
this these these mission mission
movements out into poorer areas where
you're working with people that involved
in drugs and crime and you're you're
you're you're connecting with them
you're not trying to shut yourself off
like Christ didn't shut himself off
Christ was hanging out with prostitutes
and and publicans and people of bad lie
but he didn't the thing is that people
use that excuse now
we'll say that when they want us to just
accept everything available Christ hung
out with prostitutes and well Christ
told process to stop sinning to write he
did it with love he did it by caring for
them by being with them you know and by
not rejecting them but he wouldn't have
taken them into right into the holy of
holies like he wasn't going to do that
so I think that that's the thing that
that's the balance we need to define
that makes that make sense
thinking
curiosity an adventure to go out as part
of our human experience - but I can't
help I think that like which are they
common green land
they have to live the source you have to
take the part of the center out and then
you've got to come back to the source to
recharge to be able to go back because
it's a light goes out and you could be
darkness I'd go main source the light
and we'll bring the center with you yeah
I think and I think that that's the the
movement of Pentecost that really seems
to be what it is right the movement of
Pentecost if you look at the icon of
Pentecost it starts above do you have an
icon of Pentecost there so starts above
right and then separate into 12 and then
it moves out side into the darkness it's
one of the only icons where we'll put
usually black in the door because it is
that outer the outer darkness all right
and then everybody hears the gospel in
their own language but it's they do so
it has to remain connected to the one
source at the same time right so you
have that fire that moves in a Christ
edge right I'll be with you until the
end of the age and I would say he'll be
with us also until the ends of the earth
he he goes all the way Christ moves all
the way down into Hades he goes all the
way to the edge of everything you know
but he brings life there he brings life
he's able to to care instead of not
being taken in by what's there he rather
brings light into it yes
Yeah right
neato you need to bring it you need to
evangelize your own narthex you've
gotten our thanks to you know because it
never really do people that some of
these lost nutshell it all start my own
relationship right mister me the beauty
of faith is that it offers me a chance
so that that yeah and and the idea
really and I think in our tradition is
not only that but if you move towards
the center then you will carry people
who will be carried in your wake it's a
you know there's a whole idea of acquire
the spirit of peace and saying you know
Saint Ephrem sorrow talks about this in
a thousand thousand will be saved you
know and so it this idea that you know
this idea that the Saints are the
pillars of the world they hold the world
together they they they're that
connections they're part of this
connection between heaven and earth so
if you become you go into the garden
then you'll be carrying also people with
you there's no way out of it
also source as well from you know get
out there you need a program for you
New York Road no I agree
and people are everybody is attracted to
authenticity
everybody everybody likes to to meet
people who are living what they say you
know and I and I think that that that I
think a lot of the draw of even avenge
evangelism and other parishes sometimes
that that's also what it is you see you
know your life is a mess she's someone
who's got their act together and that
they they love their neighbors and they
take care of the people around them and
they're like yeah that's what I want I
want that that's a that's that's that's
being the salt of the earth right that's
being the light of the world
yes
monsters and funny monsters it's funny
and dangerous you know bring the toll
houses right here I think he agreed they
were not gonna talk about total hug I
think I heard something in the end you
know with the freeze - freeze if someone
said about that talking about - oh no I
I think that it I think that I think the
best part about this I think that the
best version of the image image imagery
of the tow houses I think that that's
what it is that's the best version of it
then there's there's a there's dark
there's darker weirder versions of
[Music]
yeah will you in that's what the temple
has these gates to it has has different
gates the church has different gates and
so I think that for sure that I think
the best version of it is is right
that's all I'll say
fort old houses and I will read the
evidently Hart's article as well and see
what he said yes
[Music]
well depends the hero doesn't always
kill the monster the hero can also
obtain the monster even in the sort of
st. George there are actually different
versions of the story we often though
people don't realize that there are some
versions of the story of st. George
where st. George pains the dragon and he
brings it into the city and then hits
like a pet dog and so there are
different versions of the of the of the
monster sometimes the monster also
becomes human right so there are
versions of the story of st. Christopher
for example where he is this giant or
he's this dog headed man and then when
he crosses the river with Christ he
finds that he's become a man right and
you see the same story with the Princess
and the Frog there are many stories of
this idea of a monster that is
integrated into into the world you could
say that is able to find their way and I
mean it can be an image of so you could
see it as a being that has these dark
things on their edge and you kill the
thing in order to move in right remove
the layer we talked about that removing
the removing the garments so that's
killing the monster but then you can
also see it as a taming of the monster
as as making it participate in in your
life in a proper manner but we don't
believe that anything is evil in itself
right that things that are indefinite
are not necessarily evil but they can
they can be dangerous if they pull you
like they pull you out that makes sense
okay yeah there's plenty of there's
plenty of stories where you know the
story of Gilgamesh is a great story
where Enkidu is tamed and he comes and
then he joins himself with the king so
you have like the the high and the low
joining together and becoming the
perfect pair but there are several
stories like that where you have this
joining or this taming of the monster
yeah yeah and the monster I think one of
the reason to with it I think that
monster meant to show is that I think
that the monsters is meant to it's like
a sign sign that there's something
there's something going on like you
something happening when when a monster
appears it's like things aren't going
well there's a something you need to pay
attention to obviously in our life
that's true
and then cosmic in the story the cosmic
stories that's true as well your father
oh yeah go ahead
right
place
Christ
what is that what is
the thing about crisis the thing about
Christ is that Christ crisis it's hard
to talk about Christ because Christ is
more than the center Christ is the
center crisis everything Christ is all
in all and so Christ actually has that
tomb right Christ has Christ goes to the
edge right and Christ becomes the snake
Saint Gregory says says it literally
says he says Christ has become the snake
for us
Christ travels the whole thing he
contains it all and so although I do
agree that it's it's right to say the
crisis at the center that's a really
good way to see it but we have to be
careful too because it's not it's it's
so much the center that it's actually
that which contains everything in it and
so you know it's that image that I told
you about where st. gregory of nyssa
goes up the mountain and he kind of
enters into the divine darkness you know
he encounters the Shekinah the glory and
then he receives the plan of the
tabernacle and realizes that the plan of
the tabernacle is the whole thing the
whole journey from the beginning that
he's been on and then end and all the
garments of skin are part of that whole
thing
so and he says and even says he said the
tabernacle which is Christ he actually
actually said that the tabernacle is
Christ which contains everything he even
says that that that Christ contains all
of creation within him and so so I think
that that's that's why we and that's
that that when we talk about community
yesterday that's why communion is so
hard to understand because it it's not
just the center in a in a sense of
purity but it's it's that and it but
also has everything on the outside
brought in you know
because wine is a funny thing you know
wine is just why and his death turned
against itself
that's what wine is right it's
fermentation which is turned against
from which is
used flipped on itself it's a wine is a
funny thing
fact that we have that in our sacred in
our sacred the highest our most sacred
sacrament is a funny thing the blood
that flows out you know the body and the
blood that flows out all of it one
brought back anyways I'm not supposed to
talk about communion we've said that
yesterday not good to talk about that
yeah
well I think I think I think the
positive side of laughter is the
necessary need to some sometimes point
at the insufficiency of things to point
at the presumption so then I tell you
talk about them I didn't talk about that
so same accidents the confessor I always
those do this is the remedies you've
heard this a million times
so same accident the Confessor talks
about right hand sins and left hand sins
and so he says he Esther didn't talk
about the right eye and the left eye Sam
axe Allah says that left hand sins are
you know drunkenness you know sexual
sins all that sins of dissipation he
calls them right but right hand sins our
sins of self-sufficiency pride right
that's the right hand symptom so I think
that laughter can sometimes be a way to
slap the right hand sinned once in a
while that's what the gesture does right
that's what the holy fool does to write
the best the best of the holy fool is to
point at the hypocrisy point at the
insufficiency of people who think
they've got it all in that their holy so
the holy fool scratch at your holiness
because he wants to see it's real or if
it's just a show let's see what's behind
this first cover here right let's see
what comes out you know so yeah so I
think that I think that that's that's
what that's the positive side that would
laugh we can do
I think that laughter is dr. react to
something that's just not right it's
like a like a like a reacted to
something which is upside down or
something which is which is naked right
something which is accidental it's all
that there's something which is not
intended
that's what laughs that's what the basis
of laughter seems to be right
laughs at the fall there you go
well yeah well there's an example where
it's she's wrong to laugh because she
thinks she's am asking something that's
not true
she that's what you think when she
laughs she's being told something she
doesn't believe it she thinks it's a
it's a it's not it's not right it's not
possible it's not right that an old
woman would have a child and in the net
in the normal world she would have been
right to laugh but she didn't understand
the situation she didn't realize that in
this in God yeah
God was making this happen like it was
going to happen but you can understand
why she laughed I mean can you imagine
that situation today went up to a 90
year old woman and you tell her that
she's going to have a child what do you
think your reaction would be
hopefully she will have I mean I was
laughter if that happened so so it was
natural because it doesn't make sense
laughs it's something that doesn't make
sense but in this case it was God had
promised that it would happen so it's
not like it was out of the blue God had
said that this was gonna happen so she
should have known that God doesn't lie
all right so thank you if you enjoy the
symbolic world content there's a lot of
things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com